حان الوقت لبعض المرح الصيفي في الشمس
، وإذا كان ذلك يعني الذهاب إلى الشاطئ ،
فمن المحتمل أنك تقوم بنقل مبرد
مليء بالوجبات الخفيفة والمرطبات ، ولكن
بين الرمال والحرارة ، فإن الحفاظ على هذه
العناصر باردة وآمنة وخالية من الحصى يمكن أن يكون
صعبًا في البدء بالتعبئة  العناصر الموجودة في
مبردين مختلفين ، إذا أمكن ،
أحدهما للمشروبات والآخر للأطعمة سريعة التلف
لا يجب أن يظلوا في الشمس لأكثر
من ساعة ، لذا إذا كان ظلهم من
مظلة أو حتى مخزن منشفة ، فإن
المبردات سهلة
صنع وتناول الكابوبس.  وباستخدام عصا تمسك
كل شيء معًا ، لا
داعي للقلق بشأن الأيدي الرملية ، قم بتبديلها عن طريق
صنع الكباب مع الخضار بالفواكه ،
ويشدد بعض خبراء تغذية الجبن على
أهمية تناول وجبات خفيفة صحية ومرضية
عند قضاء ساعات في الخارج
في حرارة البندق.  يمكن لمزيج الدرب أن يرضي
الجوع والفواكه بفيتامين سي الذي
يمكن أن يساعد في الحد من الأضرار الناجمة عن الأشعة فوق البنفسجية
كما أنه رائع أيضًا.
تعمل عصائر الفاكهة والمياه المنكهة على الحد من
تناول الكحول الذي يمكن أن يؤدي إلى
الجفاف بسرعة تحت أشعة الشمس
الحارقة في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا كيم هاتشرسون